I am not totally a memorizer but if I
don't have some kind of notes we'll be
here much longer than seven minutes and
nobody wants that. My name is Susan Renoe
and I am the Assistant Vice Chancellor
for Research, Extension, and Engagement. If
you want to know what that title means
there's probably someplace we can meet
later and talk about it but I'm also the
PI for the National Alliance for Profit
Impacts. We're happy to be sponsoring
this event, we're really excited about it.
You've heard people say, the last two
speakers say, I don't have any answers
right because I wasn't asked to give the
answer that's why I'm standing here.
Jeannie had said we want you to figure
out evaluation metrics and come and talk
about it for seven minutes I said no
thank you.
In fact when I got the homework and I
saw that we had to talk about evaluation
I think how many feel like that
sometimes I thought that all the time I
go to meetings and conference and we
talk about it and I'm like oh this is
awful right so I'm going to talk to you
about it from four perspectives. So I'm
gonna talk to talk to you from the
perspective of Assistant Vice Chancellor
for Research, Extension, and Engagement
whose job it is to measure the impact of
the outreach engagement that we're doing
across our entire campus. Can you hear me?
Now okay I'm also gonna talk to you from
this perspective of being a PI. I'm also
going to talk to you from the
perspective of someone who works with
researchers all the time to work on
their broader impacts but all other kinds
of outreach activities and plans. I'm
also going to talk to you from the
perspective of someone who runs outreach
programs. Now you see one when I think
about evaluation my brain wants to
explode. Right so we talked for a minute
about how do we measure impact
collectively at an institution. How many
of you have read the NSF Pat G? Now when
they talk when program officers talk to
researchers about that they're like
you read that if you want to but it's a
good idea if you're bored you want to go
to sleep read it. I read it all the time
because there's lots of little tidbits
about broader impacts and things that
are in there right so I'm going to make
sure that I get everything that I know
what I'm doing
and there's a little bit of information
about evaluation. How many of you know
that researchers are supposed to include
evaluation in their runner and text
plans? Right but if you read a little bit
further it says the National Science
Board recognizes that one researcher
doing evaluation is good and
interesting but there's value in
aggregating data. How many people on your
campus are all using the same evaluation
scheme?
I see no hands right so we have to
figure out how to get get sure who
doesn't do evaluation at all none see
look he shaking his head no Jory who
does a survey, Laurie who does a focus
group, Kay who does another kind of
survey, but it's not the same questions
as Jory right so there's no way to
put that together so that's a problem.
Right how do you know how big the
average NSF budget is for a regular
person? It's about a hundred thousand
dollars a year so let's do some simple
math because this is one of the things I
do with my researchers and they're like
oh my god
Here's a hundred thousand dollars a year
right then there's a little pesky thing
called what indirect right and indirect
can be anywhere from 33% to like what
seems like a hundred percent right but
what is that please use 50 right so
hundred thousand dollars shrink that in
half right. Now everyone writes in a
graduate student right that's half your
money. Now you want to put in some sort
of summer salary for yourself. Then you
actually want to do some research and
you might have to buy some sort of
equipment and all of a sudden Susan says
you have to do money for your broader
impacts right because broader impacts
aren't free right you actually have to do
pay the people who are doing your
outreach and engagement. Right, now the
hands are stuck together and then Susan
says what? You have to write any money
for who an evaluator that's when the
wheels fall off the bus right because
then I ask the researchers how many
people have you know how many of you
know an evaluator?
Now we are not the right group to ask that
right but our researcher our researchers
are like um I don't know right or if
they do know somebody I'll say how many
of you met that evaluator because you
knew somebody who knew that evaluator.
Right I have to say it I'm one of those
people that when I wrote maybe my first
grant
I picked the evaluator that somebody I
knew recommended right. I didn't
necessarily go find the right evaluator
for the right project right so one of
the things that we do we think about ease
if I'm not really good at evaluation
which also is costly right because it
costs money so a lot of times my
evaluator costs more money than the
outreach program I'm actually evaluating.
right choices I have two minutes Thank
You Jory
So the problem is for researchers and
for all of us there's time in doing
evaluations there's cost to doing
evaluation and there's a comfort level.
How many of you flew through LaGuardia
when you came? How many of you saw the
happy buttons? I walked into the bathroom
and there's an evaluation thing I can
push the button happy man hop in you sit
in the line for the taxi queue there was
another one. How are you happy with the
service in the taxi queue? Now a couple of
things that were interesting one is they
didn't ask me if I was unhappy with my
experience in the bathroom because they
know there's only four stalls in the
women's bathroom I was really unhappy
but the question wasn't that the
question was how is the cleanliness of
the bathroom? It was clean
right so that's something else. First
thing about how do we what is it that we
are measuring the other thing that comes
out and somebody mentioned a little bit
earlier talking about impacts when I go
and I talk to at NSF this is no joke I
don't talk about broader impacts I talk
about broken impacts and why do I say
that?
One to get people's attention but two
because we don't you asked the question.
How do we know if something's been
impactful? Karen said something that how
do we know whether it's the cumulative
effect of many things that make people
go on and do wonderful things in science
or something else right? My daughter my
daughter has 15 different careers she
wants right now she wants to be an
attorney a corporate attorney and a
marine biologist studying sharks. See the
irony there right? So true in any case my
daughter goes to lots of stem activities.
Right she went to a stem robotics camp
probably three years ago. No one has
followed up to find out if she likes
science any better because she went to
that robotics camp. No one's even asked
if her grades and science are better
because she went to that and I guarantee
in another six years no one is gonna be
asking whether A she went to the
University of Missouri for school
because she went to that robotics camp
or B if she's studying thank you three
minutes
He's got more time than you George he's
tagged I got three minutes left just
saying maybe they had a reset because of
the whole microphone but no one's also
checking to see if she's gonna become a
marine biologist because she had a great
experience in that stem camp or anything
to do with that. Right that's
longitudinal data that we should be
tracking to figure out the actual impact
because otherwise our broader impacts
activities are just activities that we
think are good to do and we think are
gonna be good for people right. What's
the problem with longitudinal tracking?
it's hard to find them. What else? It's
expensive and it takes time. Right the
only people on my campus I know who do
longitudinal tracking are people who are
making programs that are getting kids
into graduate school and the
professorial and their funding depends
on them doing that right and what's the
scientific way that they do that?
Facebook. They get on Facebook and they
figure out what they're doing right and
they update that a couple of them also
finds try to figure out where they
aren't saying with them and send them
postcards right so here's the deal:
Evaluation is important. We know that the
new grant that we just wrote the
evaluation budget is the largest chunk
of money we're spending in that why
because we have to know if what we're
doing matters and if it's important and
I guarantee you that when I go ask for
more money they're gonna ask me what did
you do with the money we gave you right?
So cost, ease, comfort, understanding. What
to do and the ability to look
longitudinally and aggregate things
together are the things that I'll make
my face goal when it comes to evaluation.
So my hope is that over the next day and
a half we're going to talk about that.
We're gonna think about how we can do
that systematically. One of the things
we're doing on our campuses is we're trying
to figure out a system for helping our
researchers do that better and I'm happy
to talk about that some more so thank
you for your time. I have lots of
questions no answers and I'm looking
forward to the rest of the next two days!